ich will dass sie nicht blicken
erika modena und nicole sind kurz vor
ihrem ziel angelangt
lutherstadt wittenberg in sachsen anhalt
hier lebte im sechzehnten jahrhundert
martin luther der berühmte theologe auf
diesem markt geht das duell weiter
die nord bekommt eine ähnliche aufgabe
wie sie team süd zuletzt lösen musste
das team das besser abschneidet bekommt
ein ticket
tauscht das ei in immer wertvollere
dinge ein
ihr dürft fünf mal tauschen und müsst am
schluss einen wertvollen gegenstand
haben als das andere team
wenn jemand zuerst einmal brauchen sie
eine strategie um serien genau was was
die leute hier anbieten können gut dass
sie bei ihrem stadtrundgang den
traditionellen töpfermarkt gesehen haben
team süd hat beim letzten mal eine
kartoffel in ein abendessen getauscht
das gefühl
was können sie anbieten können wir uns
anbieten bei der sache gewesen wird das
muss
sie ist 38 euro
die töpferin ist einverstanden
sie tauscht gegen einen teller denn 49
euro wert ist
euro
ihr habt mit einer langen wir eine
vollkommen einig auch dieser händler
lässt sich überzeugen 80 euro kostet
sein kunstwerk normalerweise
neben dem töpfermarkt entdeckt team nord
den kunsthof jetzt probieren die drei
dort ihr glück
ich habe heute mit blood materialien vor
die linie 42 wirklich
man hat bilder wo man auch dran hängt
und wenn du schon mal weh wenn man denn
so ein bild verkauft aber von irgendwas
aus dem ei wurde ein bild für 420 euro
damit schaut das team noch einmal bei
nutzt flug klarer sieg für team nord es
steht 9 zu 6
man muss nicht immer wert auf was geld
liegen es gibt so viele interessante
sachen im leben
interessanter als kind
berlin
nicht braucht